نعم ، أنا متأكد من أنك إذا كنت مديرًا للنادي ،
فهذا ليس
مثاليًا ولكن من الواضح أن القرار
يتم اتخاذه لاستضافة كأس العالم في هذا
الوقت وكلما أقيمت كأس العالم ،
أعتقد أن العالم يتوقف
ويلاحظ ذلك.
أنا متحمس
لمشاهدته سواء في الصيف أو الشتاء
بالطبع بالطبع السكان من
الثقافات ونوع الاستعدادات
التي سيحبونها ولكن في
نيوزيلندا يجب أن يكون اللاعبون في
حالة أفضل مما هم عليه  عندما كانت نهائيات كأس العالم
في نهاية الموسم ، لذا إذا
كنت لاعباً الآن ، كنت
ستفضل إقامة كأس العالم ،
نعم لا أعتقد ذلك على الأرجح
لأنك تستطيع الاستعداد والثقافة التي يمكنك القيام بها
بعد التحضير مع  الفريق كيف
يريدون اللعب من ناحية التشكيل
الخ ، ولكن
هذا هو الوقت
الذي يمكننا فيه جميعًا أن نشعر بالإثارة ، لذا
أتطلع إلى مباراة إنجلترا
وكأس العالم ما هي الفرص
التي حصلت عليها  فرصة بالطبع أعتقد
أن البطولتين الأخيرتين obv  من الغريب أن تكون
مباراة نصف نهائي في روسيا والنهائي
في يورو ، لذا بالطبع لديهم
فرصة وأي فريق سيفوز
بصفقة كأس العالم سيتعين عليه تقديم
أداء جيد باستمرار ولكن أيضًا لديه
القليل من الحظ الذي تحتاجه  للفوز بهذه
البطولات الكبرى ، لذا إذا
كانت لديك فرصة لفعل كل شيء
لا يمكنهم الفوز بالوقت ونأمل أن يأتوا
هناك كان هناك نقاش حول مركز
الظهير الأيمن في فريق إنجلترا ،
أعني أنه كان هناك دائمًا هذا  الجدل
حول من سيكون
الظهير الأيمن الرئيسي للفريق هو ذلك
الاتجاه أو اللاعب الثلاثي الذي تعتقد أنه
ربما يكون أكثر استعدادًا للبدء لأنه أه
أعتقد أن القارب جاهز بالطبع
كلاهما لاعبان من الطراز العالمي في
رأيي وأنا متأكد من أن الثوم سينظر إلى الخصم
ربما ينظر
إلى ما يريده من فريقه في
مباريات معينة وبالنسبة لي أنا أحب
ترينت أعتقد أنه لاعب رائع
ما يمكنه فعله بالكرة.  يمكنك
إنشاء أهداف يمكن أن تعرفها ص  عند استخدام بعض
الكرات الرائعة في الصندوق ، يمكنك اللعب من
خلال الكرات وتعيين الكرات ، هل يمكنك
تسجيل ركلات حرة زوايا ، لذا لو
كنت أنا لعبت المعبد في Queen Trippier
Kyle Walker وهو خيار رائع بالنسبة
لإنجلترا أن تمتلكها وتملكها
بطرق عديدة  ربما يكون
من الصعب بالطبع على حفل غالا أن يختار
واحدًا وهنا يأتي دور النقاش
وأنا متأكد من أيهما
تختار أن تلعبه في لندن